there's been this article recently a
report about a hardware hack I just
thought the interesting sort sure about
what you think about it and whether it's
something that is easy to do or always
possible the original article alleged
that certain servers being supplied to
companies were being doctored for
developers with extra Hardware being
added so that they could then be used to
exfiltrate information from the
companies the report seems to have been
discredited quite heavily by other
parties whether it actually happened or
not I don't know I'm not seen any of the
servers I'm not a hardware or cyber
security expert but it's certainly an
interesting question to talk about well
what would you be wanting to do and why
would you want to say perhaps do it in
hardware so I've got a server
motherboard here so it's a standard
machine but often servers come with
extra support to make them configurable
so this is an Intel Xeon processor and
this is a for management control when
installing lots of servers you will put
them in racks of places in your data
center you've got necessary storage
cooling and things and one of the things
you don't have to do is when something
goes wrong you need to reboot your
machine to have to sort of find out
where the machine is turn it off and on
again plug a keyboard and monitor in it
to do any sort of maintenance on it so
what modern servers do is they have
these chips on there which generally
computers in their own right and they
enable you to connect to the machine
even when it's switched off and do
certain things with it like turn it on
turn it off and even interact with it so
I've got a machine at home with all of
these things in and if I just bring it
up I'm now connected to it and it's got
those things so I can look at the
sensors see what the fan speed is I've
got options to turn it off turn it up
turn it back on again reset it on some
of them I can either reflash the BIOS or
the UEFI in this case and generally
managed to the server and to the full
extent that I can actually bring up
effectively a virtual console a virtual
keyboard and display as it's done here
where I can interact with the machine so
I could login put a ISO image of a CD or
a DVD in there and install the operating
system
why would you be wanting to do this and
why would you decide to do it via
hardware rather than just getting
someone to run some malware and so we
need to sort of clot back and think
about this so the alleged what's
happened is that the third party needed
this decided they wanted to infiltrate
Hackney computers Hackney computers made
up an identification with actually be
the company's live-in go to see should
be animals were harmed in making this
completely absurd Hackney computers that
ordered I say several thousand servers
and so because when you're building that
menu it's going to be a special order so
you know probably who they're going to
and the the story goes that an extra
chip was inserted onto the motherboard
of those machines that were destined for
Hackney computers I fully believe that
it's possible to do this I think there's
enough ways you could connect things and
actually what we want you to do we want
you to get our code running inside their
environment now if you think about a
traditional companies where they
traditionally lay out their data centers
and their networks is that you'll have a
perimeter firewall around things to stop
things getting in it's a bit like the
old fashioned medieval castle right once
you're inside the castle wall you've got
a moat around it and the drawbridge of
the trough was just pulled up then you
can't get in but if you've got someone
inside already perhaps is away by a
shining light shooting an arrow over the
walls that they could communicate one
possibility is that they've added a
little bit of extra code into the board
management control and that ship
contains that extra code and then
they've got a machine ok very low
powered one on the inside of the network
while that forward management control of
the BMC is likely to be on a network
which is limited in what it can connect
to it's probably likely to be able to
connect to other board management
controllers on the same network and of
course as we've seen you can connect to
the board management controller you can
then log into the machine so one
potential thing is that they use the
board management control in the same way
that we might put a Raspberry Pi or the
cheap computer on the network and then
we can use it as a staging pose to
connect to other things these board
management controls that can also do
things like flash the BIOS and so it's
potential that actually this is used as
a sort of a staging post to actually
attack the machine itself and again I
think you would we have to assume that
they didn't actually know what was going
to be running
here they could probably hazard a guess
at the operating system and unlike the
board management controller that machine
probably is likely to be able to connect
directly out to the internet perhaps to
download software updates and things so
normally when a machine is running you
have different modes a CPU can be
executing in you have a sort of mode
where the machine has access to
everything and that's where your
operating system works and depending
whether you're on x86 and armor six
eight thousand machine it might make me
known as ring zero kernel mode
supervisor mode but at that level you've
got full control of the hardware the
machine if you can do that you can then
stop it being seen by people using the
machines you can hide it sort of rootkit
as it tends to be known but you think
I'll probably get it running as
supervisor mode and there's two ways you
can do it one you can find some sort of
exploit some part of the operating
system that isn't well written so that
you can get it tricky to start running
your code and so that's where you see
the sort of exploits things you find
some way of tricking the software to do
something that didn't intend to do make
use of that to take control of the
system the other option is that you just
get the code loaded in the place it's
the operating system so you modify the
operating system itself when this
machine shipped to hack me computers
then pack free computers will install
that operating system of choice and see
what you can't modify that then but how
does that operating system get loaded
off well that gets loaded off disk by
another program called the bootloader
and the bootloader is a program on the
disk which gets loaded by the bios or
the UEFI and the bios of the UEFI
depending on the machine is on an EEPROM
on the motherboard which can be flashed
by the board management controller and
so you can see another potential way
that you could hack the machine is that
you say okay I'll put some hardware on
the machine which modifies the board
management controller to modify the bios
of the ufi to modify the bootloader
after it's been loaded because the voice
has the permission to do that at that
point to modify the operating system
after that's loaded to embed the malware
I want to get executed and so it'd be a
nightmare to be over because he running
software which modifies software which
modifies software which modifies
and I think I've got the right number of
levels of indirection there actually
there is another way you could
potentially trick things there in that
we talk about ring zero being the lowest
level but actually when we've added
support for virtual machines and
hypervisors is now a ring minus one as
it tends to be referred to and so it's
potentially possible that you could
actually get a hypervisor running before
anything else on the machine and so the
machine was running in a virtualized
environment that they didn't know about
so that's another potential way of doing
it and again you then have access to be
able to scrape memory and find things
that were the software you can put it on
let it run delete it and it's as if it
was never there type sort of thing with
the hardware you can't really get into
the dead center necessarily and take all
the chips out that you've put in there
so you probably will make the chips look
like they're meant to be there like
they're something else or hide them so
the way a modern printed circuit board
is constructed is a printed circuit
board that Scott several layers of
fiberglass sandwiched together with
traces of the tracks of the circuit
running through them so you got the top
layer and the bottom layer but often
several three or four layers inside as
well these only got six layer PCBs and
things the story goes that actually now
the chips are so small that they're
embedded between the layers of the
printed circuit board so that actually
you wouldn't necessarily notice it I
think you'd want to design your hardware
exploit still make it look like it was
meant to be there it's only if you had
sort of one with it and one without it
that you perhaps noticed that there was
something odd about that machine
detecting it would be difficult I mean
the stories they've been sort of
suggested are that they're detecting it
mainly through odd network access and so
again that suggests what the software is
doing it is connecting just other
machines that I was not expected to
either inside the company or outside the
company and accessing things in a way
that you wouldn't expect you to do and
that is probably your sort of best bet
for detecting these sort of things is
all these machines doing what you want
them to do and the best way to do that
is to sort of monitor your network and
run software which is sort of learning
what's expected traffic and non expected
traffic and liking things because
obviously if you've got a huge data
center
thousands of machines in it spotting the
needle in the haystack is a tricky
problem so they may not connect directly
to a server and upload it all but it may
well be that they just do a domain name
lookup on certain domains depending on
certain bits of data being there and so
and that's enough to tell people that
actually ok this machine here is just
that requested a specific domain that
doesn't exist that means that it's found
what we asked it to look for and we've
just returned a specific IP address
perhaps that says go and destroy all the
machines at Hackney computers or
whatever is you wanted to do which means
that we don't tend to use it very often
horse is much further up the list so a
correct and batteries further up the
list as well I mean we all have phones
we talk about batteries all the time so
if you hypothetically picked for words
that were in the top 500 then suddenly
the search base is 500 to the power 4